like looking at a tutorial trying to
fade I think that's what happened to me
at a glory
hole so a legal team that forced Tesla's
board of directors to agree uh last July
to return more than $700 million in
compensation for allegedly overpaying
themselves are now seeking to be paid
over $10,000 an hour for their
work what so you get this
they're like hey Tesla board you guys
are overpaying yourselves we're suing
you who's who's who's suing them the
This legal team okay we're going to sue
you guys because you guys overpaid
yourselves and we're going to overpay
ourselves for the work the legal team
$1,690 an hours a lot of a lot of these
guys thew there's like leachy lawyer
teams out there that just say we're
doing this for justice but it's really
for them to make a hell of a money
almost all class LA laws don't benefit
anybody but the lawyers The Firm makes
the most yeah cuz then the people that
are in the class action they end getting
like $2 dude 30 cents and [__] you ever
get one of those checks it's pretty
great I don't I never even know why I'm
part of like some class action lawsuit
either it's like me neither used to work
here here here I guess and then they're
like oh yeah they they got sued here's
95 cents damn how do you stop lawyers do
you just ask the mafia to stop them like
I don't know were you what say you br I
don't know lawyers you hate them but you
also love them because when they do the
right thing they protect you so you need
your own team of lawyers to battle their
so it's like you have your own Army of
lawyers yeah you need like like a mafia
or like The Godfather you need your own
in-house consiliary like you do person
who's just a lawyer cuz those guys are
helpful and they understand everything
about the law and how the game works but
they're your family that's what you need
that's I need a Rudy GE that's why Asian
families are always like we need a
doctor we need a lawyer we cuz they want
one in the family I see you know what
I'm saying why do they need an
engineer to build a bridge for the
family not for long dude going to take
over and when you got a one in the
family they can talk to you about the
real real yeah you know they don't they
don't but they're not billing you the
hourly on that you know honestly this is
yeah versus like if you're just a client
they still have to maintain this
professional relationship but you can
feel like you're trying to tell me
something extra but you can't legally
say it I want my family I wouldn't go to
my family uh member as a doctor cuz I
don't want them to look at my balls
that's true or my BL hole Yeah that's
the hard one it has to be I thought you
meant you're the
doctor huh I thought you meant you're
the doctor oh I don't want to see all of
their balls either that's worse so if
approved this would be the largest ever
Uncle cough this would be the largest
ever to result from a shareholder
lawsuit filed against the board 10,000
bucks an hour how do you justify that
$229 million in fees oh $229 million
they win when they got 700 million that
that's crazy so the board of directors
is returning more than $700 million in
compensation and the legal team wants
$229 million of that in fees the irony
is [__] beautiful isn't it beautiful
who's suing like I don't get legal team
the legal team they built a case they
built a case that that the board of
directors is overpaying themselves and
then they want to overpay themselves and
then the money's going back to Tesla so
the the 700 mli
is being compensated back to Tesla and
the legal team wants $229 million I see
doesn't does mean that the board of
directors got to hire their own legal
team to another legal team to protect
themselves from their own legal team
kind of cuz the bo cuz the board of
directors is the beneficiary right yeah
so they're so are they working on behalf
of the stockholders yeah the board the
board the board is the defendants right
because this is this is my predicament
every time working with a lawyer like
okay you get this contract from this
third party right you know okay cool I
need someone to look look this over for
me so I give this contract hey M Mr
lawyer buddy can you help me out of
course here is my working agreement with
you and I'm like well who do I get to
double check this document you know what
I mean like and then I got to give this
to another lawyer to protect me from
this lawyer so this lawyer can protect
me from this person the share the
shareholders B the rest of the company
yeah right and the rest of the company
now will be paid out based on what the
board of directors compensated
themselves with so that $700 million
should be sprinkled down to the
shareholders and the company right but
instead $200 million that's going to
this legal team who are over who are
over billing so it's arguably worse that
they're even doing this at all I mean
you know I don't know that it's worse
for the shareholders no because 500
million is still going somewhere in a
sense but but now that the old board of
directors they need to hire a legal team
not to protect themselves but just to
sue the legal team that that suit
[__] crazy what the [__] now they
need a counter suit
insane some a lot of different games
being played at the highest levels
that's why sometimes it's just much more
easier to be broke but think about this
if another legal team was willing to
come in and charge only $5,000 per hour
yeah Chinese discount huh you thinking
really good like a you know what I'm
saying that's the hardest thing when I
guess from like from our experience when
Rick Ross was suing
LMFO I guess like it was to be assumed
that both lawyers on uh each side knew
that they were just going to string this
on as long as possible dude they always
have dinner with that's why when you got
the family member then you're like this
guy's actually but that's that's the
part that's harder like let's say you're
using your lawyer that you always had
like this is your lawyer right can you
imagine the risk of getting a new guy at
that point yeah it's like for sure
you're going to get [__] but you don't
go hey man why you [__] spending so
much time cuz every lawyer that you run
into is going to say I'll do a better
job I won't do that it's like but you
hardly know that guy it's like super
you're screwed and check this out the
Tesla directors have not objected to the
fee request and they're expected to
approve it um and this is kind of uh
there's almost there's common precedent
for this in uh 2012 Delaware Supreme
Court affirmed a $34 million fee from a
Southern Copper shareholder lawsuit
involving $2 billion of Damages so the
fee worked out to be $35,000 an hour
yeah I want to make that much an hour
yeah dude what the [__] that's a [__]
charger every hour yeah that's pretty
sweet that's a Dodge Charger every hour
dude I like this thing you any Dodge
Chargers I got yeah the the the state a
[__] used Sienna every hour the
state's High Court said the judges
should examine the outcome achieved and
not the hourly rate so that's crazy
that's the idea that's like okay well we
were able to save you $2 billion so it's
okay if you give us 300 million it's all
like that's how it works yeah you know
what I mean percentages but that's
different if you go up front with it
that's different if you say my Laurer
fee is
10% of whatever then that's like a
normal agreement I see but if you if
you're like okay cool we'll get you this
and then after everything's kind of sell
you're like all right now I'm going to
charge how much should we charge per
hour and then you're doing it as like an
hourly billable that just seems so much
more unethical cuz I bet you that same
lawyer is helping out this lady with a
car accident for
$100 law and ethics man it's hard to
[__] mix those together cuz it's
different from like it's almost like
getting paid Sal a salary versus hourly
right if you're like my my payment is
10% then it doesn't matter how many
[__] hours we had to work or how many
team members we had to put on this thing
it's just that's yeah that's the rate
you know what I'm saying it seems so
like you know like the government how
like you almost are an idiot for not
getting the money that you know will
come your way where it's like yeah this
is going to suck to do it this way but
like everyone's doing it why not just
get paid well that's what's crazy about
this particular lawsuit cuz like Anthony
said it's like 10% right that sounds
more reasonable this this settlement
would be
25% right wow oh yeah that's true that's
a lot a lot it's a huge little chunky
chunk are you allowed to machine gun
people down that you feel are trying to
cheat you I think I think like a whole F
in
Delaware them down I think you can but
then you just have to do the next
lawsuit yeah you're probably going to
get civil lawsuit yeah or just jail time
maybe this will stop uh them from
overpaying in the future well the
question would be would you rather save
300 million and maybe do a little jail
time no jail time I don't want to do any
jail time no jail time well that's why
you just hire somebody to do it you
promise him $50 million and he's just
the Fallout guy you know what I mean but
then that guy's like FBI get on the on
the ground like [__] oh or or he tattles
this why it doesn't work guys do you
remember that Chinese jail I mean the
Chinese court case where it was like a
[__] 100 assassins cuz they were
asking one assassin was hiring another
assassin so the job started like a
million and it kept going down to like a
thousand are you serious yeah so there
was like a like a like a RICO case
basically because every single assassin
it started like with a couple thousand
bucks and then he ratted out the other
assassin that hired him so it was just a
100 people all the way up to the person
who hired originally so dishonorable
yeah just too lazy to just do it
themselves maybe they were all like I'm
not an assassin but I'll take 50 Grand
and then they go hey are you an assassin
they're like yeah they're like I'll give
you 30 grand and then they're like all
right and then they go you know they all
they all read 4H hour work week that
month or something oh we should
Outsource this that's what happens when
you when you drop your car off at a lot
of places too they'll pay another chop
to do it cheaper what the [__] lot of
times yeah what that's why the
dealership [__] you so hard huh not
shot but they'll pay like a like you
know they'll get someone who doesn't
have their papers how do you know all
the rackets cuz I've done
that dude let me know more rackets you
got no man that's one time I went to get
a haircut I closed my eyes and another
barber came in and I looked what the
[__] who are you wait are you serious no
I'm just kid it's so weird that was
weird oh do you think that's what happen
keep your eyes shut don't open your
[__] eyes it's like looking at a
tutorial trying to fade I think that's
what happened to me at a glory hole
really get outsourced here no I went and
I met this lady and I was like oh you're
so hot and she goes okay come into this
place put your penis in the hole and
then when I I'll meet you on the other
side yeah when I got inside I put my
penis H and I came and I was like M and
then I left thinking damn she was so hot
but maybe it was a guy yeah bunch of
hair on her Knuck maybe it was a guy on
the other but I have to meet you on the
other side was there any whiskies yeah
oh any sort of little bit of stubble a
little bit yeah I heard a grunt too but
I thought that was another guy in
another room so I don't
know it's very similar to this apple
case
[Music]
man